wow man is that it that's it
you want more a little bit more get my
minder up there on that one this one I'm
20 years old recovering alcoholic drug
addict I've struggled with it since I
was 14 yes I thinks it's incest but now
I've been out for over listening I've
been clean for over a year now breasts
are just will quick okay are you just
reading webm is dr. Drew's website I
suppose say one thing what is your in
fans and so much buddy what's what's
fart rape Burt is that when you Dutch
oven somebody you force your but also
know there's a new phenomenon where like
women are telling guys not to fart
because it's called it's intrusive it's
like guys fart louder than women and now
some feminists like hardcore ones are
saying you can't fart anymore
what and then when you fart now it's
there's a new term called fart right is
that like when you farted in Krista's
mouth yeah so if I if that was real I'd
be in prison yeah okay go ahead
well help us help you Chris with your
question just farted right now all right
so yeah I feel that a community college
even though I'm bringing my grades up
now making progress that part of me
feels like I'm going nowhere in life I
feel like a failure I'm on the verge of
relapse how old is he
20 how can I stop being a little [ __ ]
and move on instead of dwelling on my
past failures your 20 good I mean it's
like here's the thing okay
yeah listen all right I got sober when I
was 17 I stayed sober until I was 30 I
relapsed everyone knows my [ __ ] story
okay but the thing is is that everything
that's happened you know from when I got
sober the first time to now I just I
wouldn't change it in any other kind of
way
because it led me up to you know being
with kalila you know do having this in
wonderful podcast meeting this piece of
[ __ ] and then
Aria you know start but everything I
have right it has to do with the past
and it all led up to this yeah you know
I met her on tinder like you know who
knows what would have happened if I you
know if I never did
stand-up or never came to LA you know
and all the bad things that have
happened for me to chipped and and get
here you know so it's like if your
journey has just begun and it's dark now
right but you know yeah yeah I think
that anything that's anything that you
want to accomplish in this life here's
the truth is like it's gonna be mostly
failure mostly mostly failure but you're
not gonna fail at all if you're not
applying yourself so you're either gonna
fail outright are you gonna fail forward
until finally something starts to click
I'm not trying to be cynical like just
life is not this whole ride isn't
structured to be [ __ ] feel good yeah
it's structured to make you see if you
can elevate above the [ __ ] toxicity
yeah and that takes a long time and
you'd you know you did it but it's like
it pulls you back down sometimes man
yeah but there is something about you
know when things for me get dark and I
know generally what's causing like if
it's drug and alcohol you know and I
feel the suffering in the pain I've have
lost you know a lot of things not my
life or you know I never lost like you
know but I lost a TV job I've done and
I've lost things you know but it's like
um and in standup right I the only two
things I did in my life that was really
kind of positive and bright is I trow a
one day I signed up an open mic and I
went up and I consistently did that and
I decided one day one day at a time I'm
not gonna pick up a drink and drug
everything else I'm a failure I don't
know how to do anything else around
those two things but those two actions
those two things that I chose to commit
to on a daily basis has got me this life
it's a great life you know and so it's
like death or to me you know if I want
to tell this guy it's just you know you
make a couple of decisions I know it's
overwhelming I have to do this and this
and I don't have a house and I owe this
person money
all these things right but to me it's
like I had all those things all those
issues that normal human beings have
especially in this country right in the
first rural country but um you all you
do is make a couple of decisions you
commit to those decisions and hopefully
those are decisions that you take big
risk I mean dude stand imagine you're
passionate about right and I was very
passionate about being sober like when I
this last time around I have 17 years
now but this first time we don't Paul
Hughes and court Macau and all these
guys this is the muffin yeah I had a
chunk but uh they you know in the
beginning they dig that they told me you
gotta hit it hard
so for eight years I every day I went to
a meeting I you know I did committed to
it I did I do the steps properly I don't
know did I call my sponsor every day I
do probably not you know but these are
two things that I consistently did so do
two things be passionate and I'll think
everything else will fall into place
what book have you read I know you
[ __ ] write a book he should read The
Four Agreements you want to change your
Miguel Luis so [ __ ] funny you say
that because when I applied I don't I
don't apply it anymore
I'm not a pickle bowl with my word okay
but when I did yeah in the first two
years that I read that book and my life
was good it's a great book where The
Four Agreements
impeccable with your word it's like yeah
I know it's ambiguous I like broke them
down to like simpler yeah but there's
like the four or cut with some of that's
why I can't I have to read the book a
couple of times yeah they're a little
and big ambiguous being pickled with
your word don't take anything personally
don't make assumptions don't make
assumptions there's a age there's always
do your best always do bit yeah yeah
like don't take anything personally is I
think in the book it says if a stranger
walks up to you with the gun shoot you
in the head it's not personal
this isn't about Nick you know which is
true you know and it's a very difficult
one to apply but it has everything to do
with them yes you're just the collateral
damage
they're demons the most interesting
people our trial by fire people
anybody who's made it through fire I'm
close with I have great friends yeah
some scars I like some people who you
know Larry Moss the great acting
instructor Larry Moss
he said something so amazing years ago
as a birthday gift I got a session with
him like a private one-on-one session
Wow
he he's more of a therapist you know
he's like he we talked about acting but
he was the one who said to me like
you're gonna spend your whole life
trying to fill a hole inside of you that
you're never gonna [ __ ] fill this is
what I want to hear and I said I don't
know what you mean he goes yeah you do
let's what happened to you when you were
kid that's causing you to do a B and C
and I broke down I [ __ ] cried in this
guy's in an acting lesson with this guy
and he goes what is the hole and this is
what you need to work on and this is
what changed my life everything from
this moment 2010 up to now he goes find
out what that void is and instead of
trying to fill it and hide it [ __ ]
show it to people share it and own it
put a light on it and make it yours and
I did wha so that's what disgusted moan
ah Wow let me see Cindy a man put a
light in your hole put a light in the
hole light in your hole all right we
would love to have you back on this
program oh thank you not being real I
know that's like that's like Johnny
Carson you gave me the knob yeah I
really I honestly and number one and if
you do your word I'd love to do it all
you want
no thanks I I am reconnected with you I
read in the connected with you all right
yeah it feels good in that way and also
honestly I'm on a thing I'm doing a
thing now
but but if I if my show doesn't get
picked up maybe we'll do something one
day you know I would look like like
pitching or pitch each other ideas yeah
and maybe we can come up with something
that's even if I'm not involved in it
I'd love I would love you know I'd love
to sit with you yeah yeah really I think
you'd be good at that talk [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah because you have a great idea
in you man thank you
there's a great idea there you're gonna
listen I'm gonna now I'm gonna blow a
little smoke up your [ __ ] it looks like
you you yeah I've watched you kill and
you're
very funny guy but you're a very
talented actor and stop selling yourself
short Bobby Lee because you can do
anything you put your mind to and I
believe this and I know your fans do it
and that's what I always wanted from you
I'm gonna give you don't give me you
don't believe it I looked at him today
let's give this young man a round of
applause Dane Cook he was [ __ ]
amazing and I was so fun
[Music]